this video was made possible by
Skillshare home to over 16,000 classes
that could teach you a new life skill
the first 500 people to sign up using
the link in the description will get a
two-month free trial
the United States is often criticized
for its disproportionately large prison
population ridiculous incarceration rate
and use of for-profit prisons and
rightly so while the total u.s.
population is around 326 million it
hosts a prison population of 2 million
145,000 compare that to the nation with
the second highest incarceration rate
China China has a population of almost
1.4 billion people nearly 20% of all
people on earth and they only host
approximately 1.6 million prisoners
China and the US have over two and three
times respectively the number of inmates
as Brazil which holds the third spot on
the list at 659 thousand
Brazil is followed by Russia with an
estimated 622 thousand prisoners and
India with 420 thousand these top five
nations alone make up over half of the
entire prison population of the whole
world which currently sits around 10.5
million people besides absurd population
numbers prisons in the United States are
known to spend ridiculous amounts of
money keeping people incarcerated
according to the US Bureau of Prisons in
2015 the average cost to hold one
prisoner for one year was about $32,000
were around 88 dollars per day though
some private or high-security prisons
spend close to or even over $100,000 per
prisoner per year as a whole the United
States spends over 80 billion dollars a
year to maintain their massive prison
system a system which many suspect is in
desperate need of reform to battle
prison overpopulation racial bias and
runaway spending one avenue of reform
that no country should or could possibly
consider is the idea of creating one
massive worldwide prison that could
house every single convict on earth of
course it's a ridiculous premise but it
is a fascinating idea what would a
worldwide mega prison look like and how
could it function for this thought
experiment we're going to take averages
from various US prisons and scale them
with the massive worldwide prison
population to get a rough estimate of
what it could theoretically look like
let's start by looking at the size of
the actual complex in the United States
the largest correctional facility of any
kind is the Los Angeles County
in California while it might not be as
high-security as a federal prison
LA County holds the record for the
largest inmate population of any
facility in the country and likely the
entire world on average this massive
complex holds between 17 and 20 thousand
inmates to maintain this number the
complex is spread across seven
facilities and 6400 kilometers on a very
basic level if we just look at the
amount of land claimed by the LA County
Jail and the average number of inmates
that would equate to about a third of a
square kilometer of space per inmate of
course not all prisons and correctional
facilities are so sprawling the
Louisiana State Penitentiary nicknamed
Alcatraz of the South and the farm is
the largest maximum-security prison in
the United States the farm holds about
63 hundred prisoners and 1,800 staff but
unlike the enormous LA County jail
system this prison only takes up about
72 square kilometers of land when
divided up on a per prisoner basis that
would give each inmate about point zero
one square kilometres or 10,000 square
meters this still probably seems like a
huge amount of space but remember that
each prison requires not only space for
inmates but also for staff recreational
areas kitchens laundromats offices and
dozens of other assorted necessities
with that in mind if we take an average
of the two prison space allowances we
get a value of about 0.16 square
kilometers per inmate now for the fun
part if we took the entire world prison
population of about 10.5 million and
built a complex using 0.16 square
kilometers per inmate as the framework
the mega prison would cover a staggering
1 million six hundred eighty thousand
square kilometers that would require a
land area the size of Alaska plus
Minnesota
then there's the staff requirements if
we compare the average number of staff
and the average number of inmates from
our two example prisons we get a ratio
of about 5.5 to one prisoners to staff
scale that to our mega prison size and
you get a workforce of 1.9 1 million
people to put that in perspective the
mega prison would have to hire every
single person currently living in the
state of Nebraska and then the higher
23,000 more
people the inmates would hail from all
around the globe with the largest groups
coming from the United States at 20% of
the total prison population China at
nearly 16 percent and Brazil and Russia
at 6 percent each comparing the United
States with other developed
english-speaking countries we can see
that the u.s. is quite the anomaly
with Canada only contributing 0.4% of
the inmate population England and Wales
contributing 0.8%
and Australia 0.4% the countries with
the very least representation in the
mega prison would be Liechtenstein and
San Marino bringing just ten and two
prisoners respectively
assuming the mega prison spent the
average amount spent in America to house
one inmate for one year the annual
housing cost for this enormous complex
would be an unthinkable 336 trillion
dollars as impossible as such a
ridiculously huge prison would be in
reality we can at least dream that an
overarching global prison system such as
this would focus less on severe
punishment and more on rehabilitation
and teaching inmates valuable skills
they can use back in society if you'd
like to learn a new set of skills I
highly recommend you check out where did
you learn to edit for me it was a long
process of trial and error and digging
around the internet for helpful video
tutorials if I had known about
Skillshare earlier my life would have
been much much easier Skillshare is an
online learning community for creators
featuring over 16,000 classes in video
editing graphic design photography and
more anyone can take a class try a
project or even teach a class themselves
Premium Membership begins at just ten
bucks a month for unlimited access to
everything as a little thank you for
watching my videos skill share is
offering a two month free trial for the
first 500 people who sign up using the
link below you can use those two months
to learn an awesome new skill that you
can use to market yourself create a
business or even start a YouTube channel
like I did there's no better time than
now to take the first step to learning
that skill you've always dreamed of
having and since it's completely free to
try you have nothing to lose be one of
the first 500 to sign up with this link
to start your 2 month free trial with
skill share if you enjoyed this video
you can watch my previous one by
clicking here or if you're really bored
you can watch all my videos by clicking
here
remember to subscribe to keep up to date
with the latest content and leave a
comment down below with your thoughts on
today's topic you can also check out my
new combined Instagram with real life
floor where we share photos of our
adventures and daily life thanks for
watching and I'll see you in the next
video